en 1965 les bulldozer était entrée en
action à rungis objectif préparer les
350 hectares destinés à recevoir les
installations d'un nouveau marché
d'intérêt national
le futur marché de paris en 1967 les
voies ferrées étaient en place les
premiers bâtiments déjà sortis de terre
et tout laissait à penser que le centre
de distribution alimentaire capable de
rivaliser avec celui de philadelphie
pourrait être ouvert à la date prévue
c'est-à-dire en octobre 1968
à cette date les halles centrales
commenceront à être transféré à rungis
libérant 25 hectares
les rues avoisinantes pas de problème
elle s'ils récupéreront leurs trottoirs
et leurs chaussée mais devant l'église
saint-eustache
que deviendra le périmètre des alpes il
ne s'agit pas en effet d'un espace libre
mais seulement d'un espace libérez
libérez que deviendront les pavillons
des halles
en effet l'ensemble des constructions
métalliques que l'architecte baltard
édifié à partir de 1851 passe pour l'un
des premiers et des plus remarquables
exemples de l' architecture du fai
réservée jusqu'ici aux fromages le sous
sol n'en possède pas moins lui aussi du
point de vue architectural ou certains
titres de noblesse
[Musique]
au bénéfice des parkings et autres
édifices souterrain peut-on bouleverser
tout ce sous sol
[Musique]
à
c'est dire qu'à six mois de la
reconversion des halles
les parisiens se pose un certain nombre
de questions devant le plan du vieux
quartier
inlassablement à l'hôtel de ville se
succèdent dans le trou des halles les
six solutions proposées projet de marien
projet arretche
projet de l'atelier d'urbanisme roger
charpentier
auger faugeron
roger marot
[Musique]
tout peut être fait sans doute y compris
restauré en priorité mais en définitive
c'est un nouveau visage de paris qui est
à choisir sur 30 hectares
un pari qui fera une large place aux
espaces verts et qui retrouvera les
perspectives de son passé
ou un pari déjà projeté vers un autre
siècle un pari monumental tenté par
l'exemple des villeneuve qui aura
complètement oublier l'odeur des frites
sur le zinc d'un bistrot des halles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le choix certes est difficile puisque
après tout il s'agit de rien moins que
du coeur même de paris et que la
vocation culturelle et la destination à
l'habitat doivent compter avec la
rentabilité du nouveau quartier
[Musique]
devant l'avenir dans la salle saint-jean
de l'hôtel de ville les visages sont
perplexes
paris est une grande affaire
[Musique]